how's it going guys Matt here for code
taking tutorials we're back for the
second part of bit set we're going to
look at the math operations in this one
we're picking up right where we left out
from the first one except now I've just
written some
um operations here at the bottom and
we're just going to walk through them
and that should give you an
understanding of how they all work all
right so let's just get right into it
we're going to start here where we left
off I'm going to hit play and we're
going to look at the console as we go
so where we're starting here is uh we're
still working with this 8-bit set I like
it because it's easy to read let's see
here that is right here after I flip all
the bits yeah so the last thing we did
in the last video was flip all the bits
the data we're working with looks like
that one one one one one zero one one so
just that position three flip to zero
everything else one all right so we're
just going to start some operations what
happens with left shift left shift is
this uh it looks like the console out
thing you're used to it shifts left and
it shifts we're doing a uh an equal sign
here which means it's destructive so
this is going to change the value in
this a 8-bit set so basically we're
going to left shift by
the binary of two so we're going to left
shift by two and we'll see what happens
so we started with this data here and
after a left shift by two you'll see
that two zeros were introduced on the
right side and everything else was
shoved so basically it just shifts
everything over by however many you say
and introduces the zeros and that's all
the left shift does so let's try right
shift it introduces zeros on the other
side and pushes everything to the right
we're just going to do it by one here
and you can see the right shift did
indeed push all those to the right and
introduced a zero on the left all right
so that's pretty weird right but if you
think about how binary works and how uh
When you're counting with it it every
time you have a new one to the left
essentially doubles that means left
shift multiplies in general now you got
to be careful with it and well okay so
if left shift multiplies when what is
what happens if you move everything to
the right you're essentially dividing by
two and these are very efficient
operations to multiply and divide which
is why they're often used it's just left
shift one and multiply by two
right shift one will
divide by two and it's not perfect
though as basically oh we did a left
shift by two which would have basically
multiplied twice but not in this case
because this is where you have to be
careful with is when you left shift if
there's already a one on the end and you
push it off you're not actually going to
be multiplying you're probably going to
be doing something weird like so you
just got to watch out for for that if
that doesn't make sense just think about
it more and how this is the maximum
number and if you push it off and
introduce zero what would happen
yeah it doesn't always work so you want
to check that bit if you're doing a
multiplication basically the number
needs to be less than half of what it
could be once you get over that range
things get weird all right well let's
make some comparisons now and check out
some other stuff yeah so we have let's
make eight bits across eight bits of all
ones which is 255 we can also just call
set on it like uh so ones dot set as we
know from the first tutorial would uh
set everything to the default which is
one uh it's const though so it doesn't
like that so in this case we have to do
it this way but if it wasn't cons that
would be fine and same with the zeros we
could do a reset since it's const we're
just going to start it out as zero
but just so you know that that is a
valid option when working with these
when it's your variable all right so
let's test the operator's or and and zor
with these zeros and ones um so if we do
an or with the last data we had that's
uh this data here zero one one zero one
one zero and we or that with all ones
what's going to happen so or Compares
bit by bit and if they if at least one
of them is a one then the value turns
out to be one so in this case since
we're comparing with all ones uh at
least one of them is always going to be
that it's going to be all once and if we
order it with all zeros then it's
basically going to be an identity only
the ones that were already one will stay
that
and you can see that that happens little
identity there so that's how or works
just Compares bit by bit and also
Compares bit by bit and does what you
would think and would do they both have
to be positive or both have to be one
software to work as you can see that
actively does an identity there as well
and if you do it with all zeros of
course it's going to come back zeros
because with and they both have to be it
and then we have exclusive or the
superior
logic block where they both have to be
different so if they both have to be
different they can't it can't be a
double match so if it's two zeros it's
going to be false if it's two ones it's
going to be false it has to be a zero on
one side and a one on the other that's
exclusive or so you can see that happens
on the first Bit Zero and one turns to
one these three ones with other three
ones just stay zeros because they're not
exclusive and so on and that happens
with the zeros and as well
and you can see that it essentially
works as an identity in this case just
the ones that were already ones since
they're the only ones that are exclusive
but uh there's some some basic
operations there and since in this case
uh I want to mention that we're doing
the math a little different you know I
said like uh when we do it with the
equal sign like so it's destructive so
it's actually changing the bits when you
use that equal science just like when
you do math normally and C plus plus but
if you're just doing a comparison like
so then it's not destructive it just
gives you the result of these
parentheses and doesn't change either of
them so just keep that in mind make sure
you know when you're modifying it and
when you're just checking it that's kind
of a given but I don't think I said it
in the first episode so I figured I'd
say it now
all right so we went all over those or
and and zor all we have left here is
just a few other operations to play
around with so first thing we're going
to do is just change it back to all ones
our variable we've been playing with
with set and you can see that right here
all ones and we're just gonna cast it to
a u long or unsigned long which is a
part of the bit set library and you can
see you can get the value out of it so
we're going to play around with these
and see what kind of uh things would get
to happen with some left shift and right
shift just as an example
so if it's 255 it's 255 there and then
if we left shift it once
um it's already 255 but normally you
left shift to multiply by two but in
this case left shifting as you can see
introduces that new zero and pushes the
leading one off there so it ends up
actually minusing by 1 to 254 a left
shift so when it's already max value if
it's max value already basically a left
shift is going to look like a minus one
so you got to watch out for that so
let's try setting it to 123 123 is uh
that in binary close to what we had it
before so if we left shift on that one
then what happens since it's under half
it's actually going to multiply it it's
under half of the max that it can be
it's actually going to multiply it so
that's when it's super efficient this
left shift is like super efficient so if
you're in a valid case where you can get
away with shifting to multiply it's one
of the most
it's one of the best ways and same with
division so when you right shift you're
basically dividing and this one's a
little bit more reliable than the
multiplication because you don't have to
worry about the half value thing or the
last bit being set this last bit of
course is worth half the half the value
of the entire rest of the the binary
number it's just the way binary works so
that should make sense to you if not
study how binary works yeah the leftmost
one is the most valuable by double the
previous one right let's continue on
here and mess with the division so we
have that 246 value from before we're
going to right shift one it brings back
down to 123. now 123 is an odd number so
when this is an odd number something
interesting happens in that it uh still
divides by two but it rounds down
so if we right shift again it turns into
61 and then if we right shift again it
turns into 30. and that's it those are
the operations so between these
operations and some creativity people
come up with some highly efficient stuff
you know of any other cool tricks let me
know and maybe we'll make an episode
three but that's pretty much it for now
because there's not a ton else those are
the main things I will say if you want
to understand the bit set even better
have a look at the
en.cpp reference and
you should be able to expand a bit more
if you want but we've pretty much
covered everything in this and I don't
know if you want to test your knowledge
walk through this example
and see if it all makes sense to you all
right well thanks for watching Matt from
Tech and tutorials over and out hope
this helped and a huge shout out to the
people that support me over on patreon
and YouTube members and all you guys
does mean a lot and it really does help
me keep going making these tutorials all
right I'll see in the next peace out